Cleopatra the seventh is one of the most
famous women who has ever lived her
story has inspired poets dramatists an
artists for more than 2,000 years
through cunning and guile she survived
to rule Egypt as all of her siblings
perished by the wayside a famed beauty
and charm led to one of the most
celebrated romances in history and the
ancient world's ultimate tragedy in this
week's biographic s' we get up close and
personal with the original Queen of the
Nile Cleopatra
[Music]
by the time of the birth of Cleopatra
the seventh in 69 BCE Egypt had a 3,000
year old history of power and decline
the country was ruled by a dynasty of
Pharaohs each with the name Ptolemy who
had arrived from Macedonia in 323 BCE
now however they faced the danger of
invasion from the menacing Roman Empire
the first Ptolemies had ruled
benevolently but their descendants
including Cleopatra's father proved to
be weak even foolish leaders as a result
Cleopatra's early years were unsettled
she knew that her family was at war with
the people that it ruled and with itself
the people suffered under the cruelty of
Ptolemy the 12th Cleopatra's father and
they resented his alliance with Rome
when Cleopatra was just four years old
the citizens of Alexandria rioted and
chased Ptolemy out of Egypt he fled to
Rome and Cleopatra's older sister
Baroness became queen
three years later Ptolemy returned to
Egypt with the help of Roman general
Pompey he snatched back power from
Berenice and ruled again as Pharaoh one
of his first orders was for his oldest
daughter to be executed Cleopatra now
had two surviving sisters and two
younger brothers all of Ptolemies
children hoped to eventually rule which
made them all rivals shortly after the
execution of Baroness the eldest
daughter of Ptolemy Cleopatra tree fauna
died in mysterious circumstances many
historians believe that she was poisoned
by one of her siblings
now Cleopatra had only one sister still
alive the youngest
arsenault she must have wondered how
long she would survive her two younger
brothers were named Ptolemy according to
the custom they would both eventually
become rulers of Egypt as Ptolemy xiii
and Ptolemy xiv by the time she was 14
Cleopatra was Ptolemies oldest living
daughter when he died she would become
queen as the wife of her younger brother
Ptolemy xiii for the young girl the
prospect filled her with both excitement
and terror vividly recalling the fate of
her two sisters she feared that enemies
might also try to kill her but the young
girl was clever she had made friends
with powerful courtiers who she felt
would protect her Cleopatra was groomed
for rulership
from her early teens she learns new
languages including Egyptian which
surprisingly was not spoken at all
the royal court all her family members
they simply spoke Greek she also used
religion to support her claim to the
throne claiming to be the daughter of
the Sun gods an ancient royal title when
their father died Cleopatra and her
husband / brother began their rule it
was 51 BC and she was nearly 18 years of
age 10 years older than the new king
this allowed her to assume full
responsibility for ruling the country it
was a particularly complex time in
addition to domestic problems which
included a discontented peasantry
brought to its knees by famine not to
mention the hostility of other members
of her own family
there were also problematic Foreign
Relations the most pressing issue was
the unrelenting demand for taxes coming
from Rome
despite the requirement of having a
husband Ptolemy the thirteenth appointed
to rule with her she didn't take kindly
to having him tagging along her solution
was to oust him from his position and
rule alone for the next 18 months
[Music]
one thing that Cleopatra knew for sure
was that she could not beat the Romans
of their military game at this point so
therefore she had to take off where her
father left off and keep appeasing the
Reimann overlords she attempted damage
control by working with the Roman
oppressors in the hope that they would
give up on Egypt entirely like a father
she chose survival but she had one
advantage over him Cleopatra she was
clever and she knew how to play the
cards that she was dealt to a best
advantage she would continue to do so
throughout her reign up until the very
end she wasn't about to fold her hands
if she could see any way to play to the
best of her ability and she would
absolutely Bluff if necessary she would
eliminate every other foe in the game
and keep a few aces up her sleeve by
willing key Alexandrians Romans and the
priests over to her side she was a
brilliant strategist even at the young
age when she became Regents however
given that she was ruling Egypt and
given the tempestuous history of her
family nothing was going to come easy to
a new ruler especially a female one her
little brother had his supporters or
should I say his controllers and they
wanted to have the power in their hands
not in the hands of Cleopatra when I say
they I am speaking mainly of a man named
Gaius Pompey who at the time was the
supreme controller of Rome the man who
gave her father the title of King and
the person who was given the right to
possess Cyprus it is highly unlikely
that Pompey saw Cleopatra as too smart
to simply be mollified as her father had
been she would be hard to control and a
constant threat to Roman dominance over
Egypt her little brother needed some
assistance and this was given to him in
the form of Roman support Pompey would
show up occasionally to formally
recognize the little brother over the
big sister as the ruler of Egypt with
Pompey's backing Ptolemy xiii went to
war with his big sister driving her from
power in 49c Cleopatra discovered that
her husband was plotting with Pompey to
send soldiers to kidnap and possibly
kill her she knew that she must leave
Egypt and so she said sail for Syria
there she hoped to recruit an army to
help her win back the throne from her
now 16 year old husband / brother
Cleopatra chose to flee to Syria because
the Ptolemies had once ruled that the
king of Syria was also an
of Rome like Cleopatra he feared that
his own country would be taken over by
the mighty Roman Empire
she took her only surviving sister
Arceneaux into exile with her this was
partly to protect the younger girl from
her brother's wrath but also to stop her
from seizing the throne herself
[Music]
while these drummers were playing out in
the Ptolemaic dynasty up north a bloody
civil war was taking place
general Julius Caesar battled and
defeated the forces of general Pompey
Pompey arrived in lucca diem in Egypt
hoping to get money food men and ships
because he was running low on what he
needed to defeat Caesar up until that
time the Egyptians had been on the
receiving end of much of the support
from Rome due to the relationship
established between Cleopatra's father
and Pompey before Caesar rose up to
challenge the Roman general and now that
Pompey had just lost badly to Caesar in
Pharsalus he needed Egypt's help
meanwhile Caesar was in pursuit and also
looking for aid for his military needs
he arrived in Alexandria with a rather
modest military force however it seemed
to the young Egyptian King and his
advisers that Caesar was going to be the
eventual victor in Rome if the King
continued to support Pompey to continue
his war against Caesar on Egyptian soil
the battles could devastate Egypt and if
Pompey eventually lost Caesar would be
enraged against the Egyptian rulership
caught between a rock and a hard place
as soon as Pompey landed with troops
palace ium Ptolemy the thirteenth had
Pompey ambushed and killed
he then delivered Pompey's head to
Caesar however the King miscalculated
how happy Caesar would be to see his
enemies had presented to him by the
Egyptian king Pompey may have been his
rival but it was up to Caesar to decide
Pompey's fate not half the upstart
Egyptian king you serve that right even
though he was horrified by the brutal
murder of Pompey Caesar wanted to keep
the peace he had come to Egypt to
collect a huge sum of money that he
claimed Cleopatra's father that owed him
he ordered both Ptolemy and Cleopatra to
meet with him to discuss a peace treaty
the now 21 year old queen saw her
opportunity to act she slipped past
Ptolemies general Achilles who is
blocking palooka Dam and sailed along
the coastline to Alexandria like way of
the Nile then she went to see Caesar at
the palace Cleopatra had developed into
a very mature and savvy young women
legend has it that she is secretive
herself in a rolled out bed roll in
order to get into the palace that this
has largely been debunked she did not
need to go through quite so covert
lengths to get an audience with Caesar
in Alexandria she
been communicating with him from her
post over the border surely before
sneaking past Achilles and heading
toward Alexandria she sent word to
Caesar that she was coming or he had
sent word to her
telling her to come either way it likely
was no surprise that Cleopatra was
arriving in the harbor that night
apparently Cleopatra donned her most
impressive outfit and took great effort
to look a most beautiful for her
audience with Caesar whatever she did it
worked a treat and Caesar ordered that
she be restored to the throne
naturally when Ptolemy arrived to find
Cleopatra in the palace reinstalled as
co-regent he was not at all pleased
in fact he threw a royal fit as
impressed as Caesar was with the Queen
he wisely took into consideration the
support that her brother had among many
of the upper crust of Alexandria
therefore he decided to handle the
situation astutely he wisely read to
brother and sister the will of their
father which stated that he wanted them
to rule together but the young king he
was not appeased he ran out of the
palace and threw down his crown in a
terrible rage and amused season aloud
Ptolemy to leave the city and join his
sister Arceneaux in Sicily days after
the Alexandrian war ended the abdicated
King spotty was found lying in the
harbor
for the first time in years Cleopatra
now felt safe her enemy husbands along
with his advisers were dead and Caesar
had promised to protect her and her new
husband her surviving eleven-year-old
brother Ptolemy xiv
with Caesar she sailed down the Nile in
order to meet her subjects and impress
them with her power rumor spread that
she was pregnant with Caesars child
which came to be known as cesarean when
Caesar returned to Rome he left a
fifteen thousand of his finest soldiers
to guard the Queen after taking control
of Egypt Caesar returned to Rome where
he was hailed as a hero before long
Cleopatra had come north to join him she
claimed that the trip was to negotiate a
peace treaty between Egypt and Rome but
she also wanted to make sure of Caesars
protection she did not want her younger
brother or his advisors to try to seize
power in Egypt while she was away many
Romans chafed the relationship between
Cleopatra and Caesar it was widely
feared that Caesar would name caesarian
as his heir and that Cleopatra would
then have a hold on the Roman Empire
through her son Caesar
celebrated his victories by parading his
captives through the streets of Rome
Cleopatra's sister arsenault who led the
Egyptian army against Caesar was dragged
through the streets bareheaded and in
Chains it was a disgrace for women to
appear in public this way at the time it
was the custom for Egyptian women to
wear a long cloak and a veil outside of
their homes
however Arceneaux was lucky unlike other
prisoners she was not killed Caesar felt
that the Romans might riot if they saw a
princess publicly executed to give
thanks for the victory of the battle of
Solace Caesar built a new temple in Rome
he also paid for a beautiful statue of
Cleopatra to be put on display in the
temple it showed her as a mother holding
cesarean in her arms
[Music]
as a reward for his victories that
Senate made Caesar dictator for life but
some Romans feared that Caesar was
becoming too powerful and that he wanted
to be king about sixty conspirators
decided that Caesar had to be killed the
plot which was led by Brutus and Cassius
was carried through immediately
following a Senate meeting in 44 BC the
shocking news of Caesars murder spread
through the roman empire like wildfire
cleopatra who was in rome at the time of
the assassination lost no time in
hurrying back to egypt now that caesar
protector was dead her kingdom was once
more in danger many hostile nations saw
egypt as a rich prize and hoped to
conquer it cleopatra kept her son
caesarian close by her side because she
feared that he might be murdered by
caesar's enemies on her return to egypt
Cleopatra found that her sister
arsenault who had been released from
Roman captivity was plotting with an
anti Caesar faction in the hope of
seizing power many of the nobles in the
egyptian court supported Arceneaux and
joined her in her conspiracy against
cleopatra at this time that nation was
suffering a crisis due to the failure of
the Nile floods there was not enough
water in the river to spread rich mud
over the fields in order to irrigate
them as a result farmers crops and
animals died as many families suffered
from famine and disease many nobles and
officials were angry that Cleopatra did
not take moves to help the victims of
the famine the tenuous situation for
Cleopatra meant she needed a new Roman
protector who she could lean on and that
came in the form of Mark Antony Caesars
murder led to three terrible years of
warfare in Rome as different groups of
Roman senators and members of leading
Roman families struggled to take control
the rival armies were led by three
powerful men and each hopes to take
Caesars place as ruler their names were
Octavian knew Caesars nephew Mark Antony
and Marcus Lepidus finally in 42 BCE the
Roman lands were divided among the three
Antony took control of the entire
eastern Mediterranean region which
included Egypt
[Music]
though he had control of Egypt Anthony
still needed Cleopatra's support and he
feared that she might support his
enemies he needed gold from Egypt in
order to pay his armies in order to keep
control of his share of the Empire he
also needed Egypt's grain in order to
feed his men
Anthony wrote to Cleopatra Rennes when
she did not reply he summoned her to
meet him Cleopatra was in no hurry to
response Antony instead she deliberately
took her time she knew that Antony
needed Egypt's gold and in return she
planned to ask for his protection she
also wanted his help to kill her enemies
including her sister Arseneau as Antony
waited for Cleopatra to arrive to the
plans meeting in Tarsus he heard news of
large crowds gathering to witness an
amazing sight Cleopatra was sailing up
the Riverside nurse in a barge its sails
purple its rowers urging it in with
silver oars to the sounds of the flute
blended with pipes and lute the sails
were made of silk a rare and costly
cloth from China
it was a floating palace the Queen
herself was dressed as the Greek goddess
of love
Aphrodite she lay on a couch beneath the
canopy of gold cloth Mark Antony was
mesmerised and he invited Cleopatra to
dine with him but the Queen refused
insisting that he join her on her royal
barge she took great care with her
preparations she wanted Antony to be
delighted astonished and most
importantly impressed she arranged for
her barge to be decorated with thousands
of tiny oil lamps and glittering
flickering patterns of lights Cleopatra
met Anthony several times during her
visits to Tarsus on each occasion she
dressed as the goddess Aphrodite
she offered Antony crowns of vine leaves
a symbol of Dionysus the Greek god of
wine she was reminding Antony that
according to legend Tarsus was the place
where Aphrodite and Dionysus met and
fell in love
Cleopatra's seduction worked a dramatic
visit to Tarsus had won Antony support
in her struggle to remain the ruler of
Egypt
Antony forgot his war against the path
ian's and hurried to Egypt they spent
the winter of 41 BCE in Alexandria
together during which time Cleopatra
hardly left Antony's side during this
time her two remaining siblings
arceneaux and Ptolemy xiv were put to
death shortly thereafter Cleopatra
became pregnant Anthony did not remain
in Europe to see the birth of his twin
boy and girl in 40 BC he had to return
to Rome because his wife vulva was
leading a rebellion against Octavian
Cleopatra continued to rule Egypt but
Antony did not return for another four
years when he sailed back in 36 BC after
a disastrous defeat in Parthia Cleopatra
welcomed him
she needed a strong ally to help keep
Egypt independent Antony plans to set up
an empire in North Africa in the Middle
East to challenge his rivals in Rome
Cleopatra supported his plans because
they would increase her own power in 35
BCE the pair had a third child a son
they named Ptolemy Philadelphus early in
34 Benton II invaded Armenia returning
to Alexandria in triumph in a
magnificent celebration Cleopatra was
crowned queen of the Kings the couple's
young children were given royal titles
over Middle Eastern lands
[Music]
top Redmond politicians led by Caesars
nephew Octavian were shocked by reports
of Anthony and Cleopatra bid to set up
an empire on their own they were also
angry that Antony had divorced his Roman
wife an outraged Octavian personally
declared war against Cleopatra and all
of Egypt even though Antony had tried to
avoid conflict with Rome it had now
become impossible to avoid this was
especially so after the Roman Senate
found out about his will in which he
declared his intention to be buried in
Egypt beside Cleopatra Antony was
dismissed from all public appointments
even though the army assembled by Antony
and Cleopatra was larger the famous
Battle of Actium in September of 31 BCE
constituted a first fundamental step
toward their defeat by now they were
considered foreigners and enemies of
Rome
Antony succeeded in taking police ium
and getting close to the gates of
Alexandria in the spring of 30 BCE and
AD well if events followed Reem added
the Cleopatra shut in the mausoleum that
she had built for herself was dead on
hearing this news which was denied
immediately after that too late Antony
wounded himself fatally and as he was
dying he was taken to the mausoleum
Cleopatra wept for Antony and tried in
various ways to take her own life
that she was watched over by Octavian's
men who wanted to take her back to Rome
a few days before her departure however
Cleopatra managed to evade surveillance
and kills herself probably with snake
poison which was brought into the prison
in a basket Cleopatra was the last
independent ruler of Egypt and her death
marked the end of over 3,000 glorious
years of Egyptian civilisation and
Egyptian power yet she could not bear to
live while foreigners ruled a beloved
country with her death Egypt lost its
most famous and possibly its greatest
ever queen so I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographic if you did
there's a couple of things you could do
right now one is hit that like button
below also if you want more stuff like
this we put out brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday so hit that
subscribe button below and subscribe
button doesn't do what it used to on
YouTube if you actually want to get a
notification about these videos please
do hit that Bell button next to the
subscribe button and that'll send you a
notification every time every Monday and
Thursday won't put out a new video also
if you want to watch something else
right now stuff from the archive over
there on the right and as always
thank you for watching